est-ce que la personnalité d'un veau
peut avoir une influence sur son niveau
de stress et éventuellement sur sa santé
voilà le genre de questions sur
lesquelles des chercheurs se penchent et
vous allez le voir tous les veaux ne
sont pas également zen
dans cette ferme expérimentale de la
vallée du fraser près de vancouver
on cherche une nouvelle manière d'élever
les vaches laitières
l'approché est plus douce et à l'écouté
des besoins des animaux plus de vingt
ans après le début des travaux
les résultats obtenus ont déjà contribué
à changer les pratiques des éleveurs
[Musique]
donc là les veaux qui sont ici le plus
jeune 4 jours et le plus vieux à trois
semaines dans ce grand gars sont
rassemblées par groupes d'âge la
centaine de vaud qui servent aux
expériences des chercheurs de
l'université de colombie britannique
donc le soleil l'a pas encore très bien
manger donc on va essayer de de
l'emmener de lui montrer quand ils sont
petits ils ont pas encore appris à se
servir correctement du fielder
automatiques ont collé on les guide un
petit peu
les veaux sont nourries automatiquement
à l'aide d'une tétine relié à un
ordinateur
contrairement aux élevages commerciaux
ou les veaux reçoivent de 4 à 6 litres
de lait par jour
c'est beaucoup plus ses volants ont
accès à 12 litres de lait par jour
de manière générale dans un hors
exploitation des nausées de lait par
jour pendant au moins un mois
on se rapproche un petit peu plus de ce
que les vos frais dans la nature ou en
fait les animaux viennent plus souvent
boire une dizaine de fois par jour comme
ils le font ici à leur mère en montrer
qu'effectivement c'est mieux pour les
animaux d'avoir plus de lait cela
rapporte plus d'énergie et quand ils ont
un problème de santé
là ça leur permet de compenser en fait
d'avoir un peu de réserve pour pouvoir
compenser si les chercheurs ont surtout
étudié la croissance et la santé des
veaux jusqu'à présent un nouveau champ
d'expertisé
s'ouvre désormais benjamin le corps ils
travaillent à plein temps ça fait cinq
ans peut-être qu'on commence vraiment à
s'intéresser à persuader les animaux
donc on évalue ces animaux sont
craintifs sont sociaux et son pessimiste
ou optimiste donc la pessimiste ou
optimiste c'est vraiment c'est donc tout
nouveau c'est que ce qu'on retrouve chez
beaucoup d'espèces que chez les veaux
ont fait ça il ya des études chez le
mouton chez le rat et c'est ici on
s'intéresse à voir si le fait d'être
optimiste ou pessimiste sa une un pack
sur sur l'animal et sur la façon qui va
percevoir les situations auxquelles ils
pointent des sujets mais aussi la façon
dont ils vont ils réagir et red star
dans un coin du hangar les chercheurs
ont bâti un enclos très spéciale afin de
déterminer le niveau d'optimisme ou de
pessimisme des vous les animaux ils sont
amenés à un haut fond de l'enclos cinq
trous dans lesquels les chercheurs
installe une bouteille de lait la
bouteille remplie et souvent placé à
gauche les animaux s'habituer à cette
configuration et assimile l'emplacement
à une récompense celle de pouvoir tu
étais à la bouteille
mais quand la bouteille déplacer
certains baux sont perdus ce à quoi
peuvent s'ajouter des punitions la
bouteille d'être vide et le
sèche-cheveux fixé au dessus du trou
peut être déclenchée par les chercheurs
résultat les veaux pessimiste tendent à
éviter les déplacements de la bouteille
se privant ainsi d'une possible
récompense les vous optimiste eux vont
tout de même si risqué car ils savent
qu'il ya une chance que la bouteille
soit pleine c'est de voir s'il ya des
traits qui permettent de distinguer les
animaux qui vont bien s'adapter à toutes
les situations qui vont être un sujet
des animaux qui vont au contraire ne
peut pas s'adapter du tout et qui vont
considérer que chaque événement
stressant de leur environnement ou une
nouvelle situation est absolument
insurmontable donc c'est des animaux qui
sont potentiellement plus vulnérables
tout ce qui peut leur arriver durant
leur vie
benjamin le corps a vérifié son
hypothèse pendant l'un des moments les
plus stressants de la vie des veaux et
des vaches laitières le transport la
corée laisser classement de vos
pessimistes et optimistes avec des
relevés de température obtenu grâce à
cette caméra thermique normalement
suffisamment d'illustrer c'est la
température de l'oeil d'augmenter donc
on s'en servent comme un moyen indirect
en fait de savoir ce qui se passe au
niveau émotionnel montré que les animaux
les plus stressés on avait une autre
opération de plus élevé des animaux qui
était décrit comme étant plus
pessimistes plus peureuse
camions de transport les animaux
pessimistes étaient plus stressés ils
vocaliser beaucoup plus sur le chercheur
c'est la preuve que les pessimistes
s'adapte moins bien aux nouvelles
situations
c'est vraiment cette population qui les
intéressait pas prendre anciennement la
population qui sera la plus susceptible
d'être stressé pour tout et n'importe
quoi mais aussi qui sera ça va avoir des
conséquences négatives sur leur santé
et la santé des vaches laitières est
particulièrement fragile après le vêlage
entre 10 et 30% de ses vaches développe
une pathologie infections ma mère ou
autre et on ne sait pas encore
exactement pourquoi
si on en croit la littérature
scientifique à l'heure actuelle sur
d'autres espèces et d'autres situations
on voit que williams
il ya un effet très délétère du stress
si on peut détecter les individus qui
vont être stressé pour tous il ya de
grandes chances que ces individus soient
plus sujets à des maladies infectieuses
en attendant davantage de résultats
benjamins et ses collègues travaillent
sur les autres émotions des veaux
notamment tout ce qui a trait à la
sociabilisation des aliments donc là on
a des veaux qui viennent de naître ou
qui sont nés dans les derniers jours
ici on les garde que 5 jours maximum en
enclos individuel jeu pour s'assurer que
tout va bien ensuite on les met en
groupe soit là bas la pratique qui était
majoritairement fait qu'ils aient
toujours majoritairement en fait c'est
d'un regard des cvo seul pour les visons
les deux premiers mois de leur vie le
temps qu'ils se sauveront les
nous ce qu'on a montré c'est que les
veaux qui était mis en groupe avait de
meilleures capacités cognitives
meilleures capacités sociales capacité
émotionnelle
on a montré que par exemple une chose
très simple à faire il peut être fait
dans n'importe quelle ferme c'est
enlever cette foison
[Musique]
elle permet trop vaut au moins d'être en
interaction l'un avec l'autre
donc ça améliore leur capacité cognitive
sa meilleure capacité social et
émotionnel
[Musique]
dans cette ferme laitière à quelques
kilomètres de là rogers rustenberg
appliquée conseil des chercheurs de
l'université de colombie-britannique
dans ses ruches blanche
les veaux passe les premières semaines
de leur vie ils sont ainsi protégés
notamment des maladies avant ou leslie
vaut plus longtemps dans les ruches mais
les gens aient lieu bissy nous ont
conseillé de les laisser sortir dès que
possible pour qu'ils puissent interagir
avec les autres vos après avoir regroupé
ses veaux nés sans rigueur a remarqué
que les animaux étaient plus sociable et
plus dynamique plus rapidement et pour
qu'il soit plus résistant aux maladies
il a aussi changé leur régime
alimentaire ils m'ont dit on gueule tu
ne nourrit pas à citer vogler faut
davantage de lait ce devrait leur en
donner autant qu'ils en veulent ils plus
tôt j'ai dit vous êtes sûr j'étais
sceptique parce que pendant des années
on m'avait conseillé le contraire
maintenant je leur donne 4 litres qui
finissent ou pas et le soir une autre 4
litres grossistes privés sont en
meilleure santé ils sont sevrés plus tôt
chaque semaine benjamin nos corps quitte
sa ferme expérimentale pour venir
rencontrer ses collègues à vancouver à
l'unité de recherche sur le bien-être
animal
le travail de benjamin est à
l'avant-garde de la recherche sur le
bien-être animal gommage jusqu'à tout
récemment il n'y avait aucun outil pour
évaluer les émotions des animaux de
ferme nous personne n'avait jamais fait
ce genre d'étude
les fermiers ont beaucoup de décisions
difficiles
on veut leur fournir des données
scientifiques pour les aider à faire les
meilleurs choix possibles
pour beaucoup d'éleveurs entendre parler
de personnalités d'émotion des veaux ce
n'est pas une nouveauté
ce qui est maintenant différent c'est
que les chercheurs ont les outils
scientifiques pour évaluer ses états et
pour mieux comprendre comment cela peut
affecter la vie de ces animaux pour les
éleveurs ça une importance assez les
hammers sont aussi très conscients que
leurs différents animaux en différentes
personnalités ils sont aussi très bon
pour savoir qu'un animal est très
peureux ou c'est un animal est très ou
trop amicale donc si on a vraiment une
des bons résultats sur le fait que aussi
si vous avez des animaux qui sont trop
peureux c'est pas bon pour eux ça sera
facile pour les éleveurs de faire plus
attention à ces animaux
[Musique]
dans l'après-guerre a été difficile pour
nos fermiers pour bus et noir se
produire beaucoup de nourriture à faible
coût a parfois péché de bien s'occuper
des animaux
aujourd'hui ça a changé
donner une qualité de vie aux années
je pense que ça permettra aux fermiers
de produire dans le respect de leur
valeur fondamentale
[Musique]